there is a theory i'm developing with
collaborators that we're using for life
detection which is called assembly
theory it was first developed for
detecting alien life but the way we
think about it if you take something
like a molecule
or a person we would say in this theory
that they're an assembly space for a
molecule it's very easy to visualize so
you take a molecule if you break it in
half and you break it in half again and
break it in half again you can get to
elementary building blocks and then you
can take those and try to reassemble
them like imagine you have a stack of
red and blue legos and you take them
apart and then you want to find all the
ways to reassemble that original object
in assembly theory those more complex
objects have longer and longer shortest
paths for assembling them and so we talk
about the shortest path to make
something as being an intrinsic feature
of the objects and then the argument is
that if you had
if you see a complex object and it
requires too many minimal steps for the
universe to produce it then it's a
signature that you had a living process
there or something that had information
or knowledge about how to make that
specific object
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today is pretty intense on the show is
sarah walker she is an astrobiologist
and a theoretical physicist
she is interested in the origin of life
where did we come from how are we here
and potentially life on other worlds
learned by
understanding ourselves so
before they started i told my producer i
was like this is getting to the edges of
my intelligence meaning like we crossed
over that quite a few times
um but i don't think there's any other
way to learn other than getting outside
of what you already know
so today was a very
interesting enlightening confusing
conversation about
life and how it came to be exploring
concepts of
biology quantum physics
uh time um that's something that's
really
interesting to her is this relate our
relationship to time and if time exists
and that's what ends up being sort of
the causal
causal platform to create life and
universes and everything and so
yeah i mean if you're into science or
how life evolved
you're going to enjoy today and you're
going to be left thought provoked and i
think that's the best place to be
because if there's one thing that is the
truth about
scientists is that it's an endless
list of questions
uh without answers and the goal is is
that you figure
a couple of them out in your life and so
at the end i ask her what that question
is that she'd like figured out i hope
you enjoy the show if you like what you
hear today and have maybe listened to
other ones and like those please hit the
subscribe it means a lot to me and also
if you have any thoughts in the comments
i'm going to be reading those because
this is a fascinating topic enjoy what
happened when you were a kid that you're
like i want to understand
what life is
i love figuring out stuff that no one
knows
um
i don't think i knew that when i was a
kid actually when i was young i wanted
to be an artist um because my dad's a
hair stylist and my mom uh does interior
decorating and i just came from a very
sort of creative artistic family
but i think what really got me into
physics was actually i was at community
college and i was just interested in
science i took all the science classes
and i was so deeply fascinated by the
fact that
human minds could come up with ideas
about how reality worked write them as
mathematical equations make predictions
and then go and find these things that
we just never anticipated could be there
um so the example was my favorite was
magnetic monopoles which sounds kind of
silly but every magnet that we've ever
come across has a north and south pole
so a simple idea is could you have an
isolated north or south pole and there's
these
objects in particle physics that have
been predicted that people are looking
for it i was just like that is so
romantic
so so that was it for me was just the
fact that you know we can think so
deeply about things and actually look
for them
this is actually something i've observed
with a lot of people that have
discovered
brilliant things
and that is
there is almost like
an awareness for a dynamic
that you then spend
years or decades
backing into
the reality the way to an equation for
it it just seems like this is a pattern
do you is there and does that ring a
bell and if it does then is there
something that was happening in your
reality in your world where you thought
i just i know this is the case i want to
figure it out
yeah
except i think it's exactly as you
describe or you don't know what it is um
right away and you start to realize that
over time so for me um i became deeply
um infatuated in a sense with
theoretical physics and the the sort of
um beauty of the theories that came
before and
um and the fact that you know we could
do this we could write down equations
and so i thought for um my undergrad and
my starting grad work that i wanted to
be a particle physicist or a cosmologist
because i thought those kind of
physicists studied the most fundamental
things right so you learn about quantum
physics and general relativity and
you're like that's it that's what it is
but what was interesting was my phd
advisor was interested in the origins of
life and he wanted me to work on a
project in that so actually what i did
is i started working on it because i
thought i could just work with him and
then i would gradually get into those
deeper questions but what i realized was
um
you know thinking about the problem of
life and how life arises in the universe
is
this really open scientific question
nobody had an idea about how to address
that question and what kind of theories
we should be thinking about to explain
what life is and for me that became you
know really sort of the signature of the
kind of science i wanted to do because i
was looking at past generations and what
they had done but of course those
theories are they're not complete
they're always subject to revision but
they're about parts of things we know
and here was this frontier of what we
didn't know and if i wanted to be one of
those theoretical physicists working on
the edge of what we didn't know here was
the problem
um and so so then then i realized that
working on life was actually the way to
fulfill doing fundamental physics for me
because it was at that creative boundary
and then um as i worked on that problem
more i've come to do this sort of set of
thought experiments i really like which
is you know there's theoretical physics
where we write math equations and we use
them to describe the world and then i
like to look at that from the outside
being somebody studying life and i and i
think about it in some sense what would
be the physics that describes
theoretical physicists you know what is
the physics of people or minds in the
universe trying to understand the
universe
that's
in effect physics of life right so so
then that goes back to the original
motivation i had to be a physicist in
the first place because what really
caught my interest was this
correspondence between our ability to
comprehend nature and the fact that
nature is comprehensible
and i think there's some some really
physics we don't understand about that
structure yet
what do we understand about nature at
this point and what what what have been
the most
recent discoveries even about nature
um and are we talking about nature
meaning like trees and bushes and stuff
or are we talking no i mean reality
reality yeah so maybe that's a better
word we're talking about reality yeah um
nature um
yeah um what are the most recent i mean
i can tell you about the things i'm
excited from my work but um but i think
it's a very sort of non-traditional kind
of physics so um so i think one of the
things i find interesting and
challenging is
um you know there's sort of a standard
doctrine in the way that we talk about
physics as it's been invented over the
last 300 years so i think people forget
that physics itself is a creation of the
human mind and it required a lot of
ingenuity of people
uh like galileo and newton for example
to actually come up with sort of the
first real theories of physics so one of
the first major theories in physics is
obviously like the theory of gravitation
um and it was ex
powerful in its explanatory power
because it basically for the first time
in human history we understood that the
motions that we see in the night sky can
be described by the same things as we
see on earth
and i think people really don't even
appreciate the fact that for most of
human history we thought the heavens
were governed by different principles
and different laws than things here on
earth um so that was a huge conceptual
leap a huge amount of creativity to come
up with those kind of theories but they
have a certain structure to them because
they were explaining things like
gravitation or motion um and you know so
if you want to build a theory that tells
you about how all objects move in the
universe from you know uh the pen i'm
going to drop on the floor to you know
you and i stay in our chair to start
startling satellites moving across the
night sky or planets you know all these
things are described by common laws but
it doesn't mean that the structure of
those laws actually describes other
phenomena that we observe
like life the simplest way i can
describe the sort of dichotomy is
actually to go to a quote from charles
darwin which is a very famous one which
where he talks about wilst um you know
the planets have been moving around the
sun uh due to the constant law of
gravity um endless forms most wonderful
are being evolved and continue to be
evolved i botched the quote but i think
you know he wasn't a very eloquent
writer but that was probably one of the
most eloquent things he ever wrote
there's the structure for the laws of
physics um that we assume the laws exist
outside the universe and they're fixed
for all time and and that was kind of
newton's concept because he believed in
sort of an external being that might
have written down the laws of nature and
actually set the universe in motion and
darwin is kind of making this argument
against that kind of conception of the
laws of nature because when you look at
biology you're constantly seeing change
in innovation and creativity in the
biosphere that you don't you don't see
in gravitating systems or in quantum
physics um and so what i'm interested in
is what is the structure of that
creative process in the universe the
thing that we call life
and i think it has a very different kind
of physics and in fact the kind of work
that i'm doing with my collaborators
really suggests that we should think
about time as being more fundamental and
some of these other properties is
emergent of time in the sense that
certain things in the universe don't
exist unless other things existed before
them so i would say like my cell phone
is the product of four billion years of
evolution on earth they don't
spontaneously fluctuate into existence
because quantum mechanics tells us they
do that's just that's a wrong
extrapolation of that theory um to
explain the complexity of this object it
actually requires a specific causal
chain of information being acquired in
the universe about how to build a cell
phone which is what we call the
evolution of the biosphere we're using
this
phone to communicate with each other at
sort of this
density and reality of existence but
if we
look to something like quantum
entanglement or
telepathy or
remote viewing or all those kinds of
things like you don't actually need the
telephone they just are kind of local to
this experience
yeah so certain ones of those i might
say i were more reliable phenomena in
the sense that you could set up
experimentally boundary conditions and
test it um but i would say a general
feature of that kind of thing
from the the way that i might talk about
that kind of phenomena from the
perspective of thinking about living
things is
um
that they actually are connected by a
causal sequence of events so
there is a theory i'm developing with
collaborators that we're using for life
detection which is called assembly
theory
and
well it was first developed for
detecting alien life
but the way we think about it
is actually deeply related to answering
your question from the perspective that
i think about it
which is if you take something like a
molecule
or a person um we would say um
in this theory that they're an assembly
space for a molecule it's very easy to
visualize so you take a molecule if you
break it in half and you break it in
half again and break it in half again
you can get to elementary building
blocks and then you can take those and
try to reassemble them so think like
legos like imagine you have a stack of
blue red and blue yellows legos sorry
red and blue legos in a stack
and you take them apart and then you
want to build find all the ways to
reassemble that original object um and
assembly theory the way we talk about
a molecule is a molecule is actually all
of those
pathways for building it but you can't
see them unless you actually look at it
across time
and this becomes important um because
when you look at that
that let's say you built um not a really
simple step stack of legos which if you
had some random kinetic motion you might
maybe expect to spontaneously
self-assemble but let's say you're like
my son and you really like harry potter
and you built like the hogwarts castle
what's the likelihood of you being able
to assemble that object and this is
where we say you know the likelihood of
that particular configuration is very
low
um in assembly theory those more complex
objects have longer and longer shortest
paths for assembling them and so we talk
about the shortest path to make
something as being an intrinsic feature
of the object so
um and then the argument is that if you
had
if you see a complex object and it
requires too many minimal steps for the
universe to produce it then it's a
signature that you had a living process
there or something that had information
or knowledge about how to make that
specific object
now this gets important to answering
your question because if i have a set of
objects like people um what it suggests
is they're they're not independent
phenomena so one of the reasons i was
laughing about the idea of a phone
spontaneously fluctuating out of the
quantum vacuum is i don't think a human
could ever emerge in isolation in the
universe they always emerge in groups or
populations because there's a set of
causal constraints that's actually
generating the phenomena we call humans
and they're connected in their past by
the set of ways that the universe could
make them this sort of assembly space
and you can actually look at the causal
constraints in that space and say how
likely it is to get this set of objects
so when i think about people i don't
necessarily think
about us as individuals i think of us as
sort of um
a lineage of this kind of information
structuring matter across time and that
we're connected in
across time in a really interesting and
fundamental and physical way and that
may manifest so for example an
entanglement
if you thought time had a physical
dimension in the same way that space has
a physical dimension it'd be very easy
to say that those things are actually
connected more fundamentally
in terms of being having been localized
in time and space is this emergent
property that makes them look like
they're separated and this is something
that happens in sort of causal set
theories for quantum gravity the way i
talk about it which is supposed to be
one explanation for quantum gravity but
um so so so i guess my my short answer
is
i don't think it's impossible for us to
have some understanding and overlap uh
with each other in a sense that even
when we speak language right language is
a weird thing to think about as a
physical
object like what is a word as a physical
thing yeah
and the reason that we can communicate
is because we share a common history
because we're the same lineage we're
part of the same example of life in the
united
story of life evolving over 4 billion
years
well why do they i mean i would imagine
that this is
this theory is intriguing and could be
really powerful is because
from all the things that i read and
learn about is that
people say that in the
quantum field or in the universe time
this is a we're in a time space reality
in that in
outside of this time space reality there
isn't time anymore and everything exists
simultaneously
yeah why where does that come from what
is the actual science that they're
implying when they say that
time does not exist
um
yeah i actually there are any no i so i
i think um so here so
so
the thing that i think people
have a hard time grasping about physics
and this is even true for practicing
physicists and some of the best
physicists in the world is that physics
is you know a set of theories that
describe to best approximation certain
phenomena we see in the world and they
can suggest features of our reality that
are imperceptible to us like for example
the fact that i'm sitting in a curved uh
space-time uh geometry right now because
i'm a massive body attracted to another
massive body right like that i i can't
perceive that with my sensory perception
but i can infer that based on being an
intelligent being i think the the thing
is like how far can we extrapolate the
theories and and then the question i
have related to that is
when do you decide that your
extrapolation is non-physical and i
think because it doesn't conform to
other features that you observe that
maybe you don't have an explanation for
and the places where you see this come
up most clearly are where say
fundamental physics interacts with
everyday experience or intuition um and
there are real conflicts there like you
know people that study physics and want
to you know explain everything in terms
of the structure the standard model will
say there's no room for free will
because the standard model explains
everything uh because it explains what
your elementary particles are doing so
therefore you and i don't exist we're
just epiphenomena and i i don't think um
i don't think that's adequate because it
doesn't explain a lot of features of our
experience and so the point about time
is there are certain models of the
universe that time doesn't exist and in
standard physics time needs to be an
emergent property it's not a fundamental
property
and so so what people do
is they ha they spend a lot of time
trying to show how time emerges from
fundamental physics
and some of the places that might come
up are thinking about um you know
entropy like the increase in disorder
the universe has a certain
directionality to it um or
um you know actually having a process be
irreversible in in an entropic sense so
so these are these are certain
ways of trying to show that there should
be a directionality in time but there's
also other senses you could think about
time there's the flow of time which is
our perception of time so that's
psychological and then when i talk about
time i actually mean the ordering of
events that can happen
um which is another concept of time
and when when i was talking about this
sort of idea of thinking of ourselves as
these assembly structures like these
these causal structures of you know like
i exist in the universe in sort of
theory we're thinking about um
as all of the ways the universe could
assemble sarah i'm a unique object in
the universe but i i contain a lot of uh
baggage if you will but like a lot of
history right i'm uh you know i i i've
been i've been generated in this
universe over four billion years of
evolution of life on earth um and um and
time becomes fundamental when you're
thinking about that because there is a
clear ordering that um you know i
couldn't be born before my grandmother
it's a it's a causal impossibility um
and i think um you know there's some
paradoxes and and relativity associated
with that that get resolved by certain
features of that theory but i think
what
when i think about relativity i don't
think about relativity as being a theory
that actually talks about time i think
it's a theory that talks about
simultaneity and i think part of the
problem with all of these concepts is
we're all using the same words but words
are imprecise to reality and we we
slightly construe them based on our
perceptions of what we think they mean
and then we get in these kind of
narratives where people are using the
same words in different ways and then it
becomes very confused what's happening
and that happens in science
among you know some of the best experts
in the world don't always know what each
other are talking about when they use
certain words like time or space well
space is a little bit easier space
actually much easier um but then you
know when we talk about it popularly it
also becomes
uh you know quite different and
and i think it's important to be aware
of the fact that when you're working on
the boundary that some of these concepts
may not really be understood in the way
that we think we understand them
is there
some kind of intersection between
um
perhaps the past or even the future
and time
based on and so i'm just kind of riffing
here i'm no
astrophysicist i am just a curious
curious you're alive which means you
have some window into the physics of
life
i suppose um but this we're hurling
through space like we're not sitting
idle right the whole thing is expanding
we're expanding we're spinning we're
hurling through space
we're moving
so
is there some kind of
motion happening in the universe where
our positioning intersects with other
sort of energetic time codes that have
happened at other times not meaning the
time didn't happen
it's just and it's just intersections of
them
um
to an extent yes i'll give you one of my
favorite examples
of this which is a very concrete science
example but it goes back to this idea of
thinking about the physics of
theoretical physics
physicists which is um to think about
the example of first contact with
gravitational waves so a lot of people
are interested in first contact with
aliens what will they look like will
they be you know on a different planet
will be some interdimensional thing if
you're getting a little bit more
speculative but you know like what will
that first contact be like and my
argument for thinking about making
contact with other life forms is we have
to have an understanding of what we are
and what we're looking for before we
design the technology capable of making
contact um and part of the argument
actually comes from just thinking about
the structure of the evolution of our
understanding of gravitational physics
um in the sense that
you know i gave the example of newton
you know unifying terrestrial and
celestial motion and then einstein
unified space and time right in his
conception of gravity um and what he was
able to predict from that was this thing
called gravitational waves right so
gravitational waves are ripples in the
fabric of space-time if you didn't
invent a concept of space-time you would
never fathom these things could exist
they're ripples in the fabric space time
but gravity's very weak force so they're
very tiny ripples
and what happened was einstein put that
idea out there and people thought it was
plausible because of all the other
predictions relativity made but we
weren't able to detect that particular
feature and it took a hundred years
for us to build an interferometer which
is a very sensitive instrument they're
four kilometers across um they can
detect vibrations of a proton on the
scale of you know like a fraction of a
proton i think it's like a 10 000 the
width of a proton they can detect
perturbations do the rippling of the
fabric of space time and um in
2015 i think it was or 17 i always get
it mixed up um
we actually detected a black hole merger
that happened in our universe now that
black hole merger was an event that
happened 1.4 billion years ago in the
history of our universe because it was
14.4 billion light years away and those
ripples have been propagating across our
universe for 1.4 billion years and it is
only because
we happen to be a planet that evolved
intelligence that intelligence
identified certain regularities in the
world and formalize them in laws of
physics and develop technology to
measure properties of those physics that
when that 1.4 billion year ago event
happened to intersect our timeline we
actually could measure that phenomena
happening but what was happening on
earth at that time was we weren't even
multicellular we were just you know
microbes on this planet when that event
happened in in the past of the universe
so that's an intersection of some really
interesting things that have happened in
our universe the evolution of
intelligence detecting this event um and
actually recording it right so
um so i think i think you know you can
extrapolate that as you will to what
kinds of things we might find in the
future but i think one thing that's very
clear is if you have physical systems
that are capable of generating knowledge
as humans are and our biosphere is
it causes really interesting
intersections between
what happens in space and time and what
gets
picked up basically by sensory apparatus
or detectors or
things so you were talking about you
know us beginning as
biological
systems and producing us
um
my understanding is that life started
pretty quickly on earth yes
that's what we think yes and so evidence
is in favor of an early start
how is that possible
what
what are the ingredients to
make that make to make life
yeah so um a lot of people that work on
the origins of life which is the area of
research that i i spend most of my time
thinking about is actually like how does
life even come to be in the universe um
think about you know trying to generate
an individual cell
um and making some of the molecules that
are involved in biology now
and i think
i think that's not really the right way
of framing the problem i like to think
about the original life much more as a
planetary phenomena that some planets
actually transition into this cascade of
open-ended complexity and evolution that
we call a biosphere
and some planets don't they just get
stunted um early on um and then it has
something to do with the geochemical
complexity of that world like what were
the chemical ingredients on that planet
how were they being mixed what was the
density i i think of like a density in
in this sort of assembly space what was
the causal density of like an amount
density of information actually generate
this kind of very
um uh this very different kind of
process and this different kind of
physics that we see in life and well i
watched cosmos and neil degrasse tyson
show just how fragile life is yes it is
um well actually i you know i i
it's interesting when you're working on
this problem so much i come to disagree
with a lot of the standard doctrine i
don't actually think that life is that
fragile i think life is one of the most
robust features of our universe uh when
it evolves because
if you think about um
i mean it is we are fragile in the sense
like if a meteor hit the earth you know
actually right but we're not fragile in
the sense that
we are capable of inventing technologies
that can get us onto other planets and
also allow us to live in air-conditioned
homes at a comfortable temperature that
we don't have to fend for food and
biology has been constantly innovating
to basically increase its staying power
over you know four billion years um so
uh so i think i think if you think about
the most kind of robust processes that
can exist in the universe i think
intelligence is probably it as far as we
know um whereas all all other sort of
events in the universe that we
understand from standard physics require
specially tuned initial conditions and
some kind of random chance of events um
like
so but intelligence is very reliable if
i know how to do something i can do it
again and i can do it again and again
if you say intelligence are you
talking about
consciousness
or are you talking about
biological objects ability to
have a feedback loop that
perpetuates growth and evolution
to some extent i might be talking about
both um and again this goes to the fact
the feature i was talking about earlier
so i'm glad that you're asking about
word choices because i think that's very
perceptive of you um
that um
because the words are always imperfect
they're they're not very best yeah
they're not the best i wish we could
communicate a different way than
language but we're not there yet
consciousness like as i understand it as
a scientist like the future of
consciousness that's always mysterious
and the one that you really want to
understand is why we experience the
world right so so usually in the
scientific community we separate
intelligence or even thinking about
neuroscience from the problem of
consciousness because consciousness is
in the sort of special bin where we're
not sure that it actually can be
addressed scientifically because um you
know i i'm having a certain set of
experiences of this conversation right
now and you are too but there there
doesn't seem to be any direct way of
building a map between what my
experience is in your experience or even
directly testing you have experience
because you you can tell me you're
having experience but how do i validate
and how do i look at the inner structure
of your experience from the outside it's
it's not um
it's it's not um it's not that it's a
it's a well-posed problem but it's not
necessarily well prose for science and
sometimes you know uh when i think about
the long-term future
um you know pending we survived long
enough there there might be something
beyond science not in like like science
was invented right and it's a really
rigorous way of thinking about reality
but there might be some ways of thinking
that are even better than sciences that
allow us to probe that question directly
sure i mean neil degrasse tyson said
that the his greatest fear was that
he didn't know the right question to ask
yes yeah no that's that's a
that's very
good i also agree but on the nature of
consciousness i do think there are ways
of thinking about it from the outside
what might be happening on the inside
and the way i think about that is to say
like if you thought about imagination as
something that you want to explain from
physics um imagination is kind of a
weird thing right so
um the example i like to give is like
rockets the idea of rockets have existed
on this planet for hundreds of years but
we only were able to build them in the
last century so is that an example of
something that existed only within minds
and maybe mine's writing on paper
but then was actually physically
generated in the universe because those
minds had access to that idea they
invented that idea before they generated
physical structure so i think when you
were was there two two options did you
the well i think no i think that's what
like i think that's a good probe into
what the nature of consciousness is and
i also like to think of consciousness
uh more in terms of sets of collective
interactions so i have a colleague in
japan takashi kagami who you know was
trying to play around with the idea of
whether consciousness was contagious
which i think is kind of an interesting
concept could you learn consciousness
from interacting with another physical
system so in the context of like could
we teach robots to be conscious by
interacting with us in a meaningful
interaction
um
but
and that raised for me interesting
questions about are we only conscious
like even though consciousness is an
internal thing maybe we're only
experiencing consciousness because it's
actually a collective property it has it
requires groups of minds interacting
because it's actually about the
information we exchange with each other
that actually is our conscious awareness
so um so i think those are all sort of
plausible ways of maybe formalizing
theories of consciousness that could be
tested um
particularly the imagination when like
if you imagine that counterfactuals
things i could imagine could exist but
don't exist now could be caused to exist
by an entity that could you know a
physical thing like me that can invent
them i mean the reason i think about it
this way is exactly what you do when
you're trying to make a theory of
reality right so
when you're trying to sit down and
you're trying to say i'm looking at all
of the patterns that i see across all
life all the ways that we talk about it
and i'm trying to make an abstraction a
set of ideas that allows us to now
control that phenomena not control it
but like actually understand it in a way
that we can now use it for different
things and
and gravity again is the example like
why can we watch that satellite launch
satellites into space right now we can
do it because we looked at a certain set
of patterns in the world and we were
able to come up with this abstraction
that explains a large class of them all
the things that are gravitationally
interacting and then we use that to
develop technology to be able to do
things we were never able to do in our
history uh same thing with time i mean
like the invention of clocks and the
progression of our ability to use clocks
and keep track of time i mean seconds we
take for granted now it's like you know
seconds are passing when we're doing
things but for most of human history the
idea of a second was impossible because
they had no no id no capacity to keep a
record of a second i i start to think
about whether or not anything can be
objective what do we define as objective
and then can we make a case that
anything is even objective if it's
collective if that's how we build
build systems or theories like if that's
how consciousness is grown there's
nothing i mean
it seems hard to make anything actually
objective
so i
i mean you would enjoy your upcoming
workshop in the beyond center because i
have a workshop i'm organizing in april
which is called i'm here i'm local yeah
infinite turtles are ground truth right
so does reality actually have a bottom
level or is it just turtles all the way
down okay let's start with objective
what is an objective truth how do we
actually qualify something is truly
objective so i don't think we can do
that um but i i would say that for me as
a physicist i
operationally i have to assume
something's objective because you have
to build a scaffold from something you
believe to be true to construct ideas
about
what would follow from that that set of
things being true um and so
so i i can think about this sort of
again it goes to like thinking about
life right so so life has evolved you
know over this history on our planet and
we're continuing to evolve and acquire
new knowledge um and so for me it's the
knowledge that actually matters is the
the knowledge that
um stays like it persists over time
because it actually has some
correspondence with the real reality out
there um and the real causal structure
out there because it's basically how we
move through what exists okay um so so i
think of like uh the trajectory of life
as moving through the possibility space
of everything that could exist but it's
very constrained by what exists now and
what we can actually generate from that
and part of how we generate what
is happening in the
techno sphere like all technology that
exists on our planet today and what
might exist in the future is actually
imprinted in some sense and what exists
now and what we can actually generate
from that knowledge so it is subjective
to us
it's subjective but it's also objective
so our subjective perceptions of things
becomes objective because we're real
physical systems and we use that
subjective understanding to do things
um and unless that subjective
understanding actually has any
correspondence with reality it's kind of
useless information and it gets lost in
the sort of evolutionary filter because
it just doesn't persist over time yeah
it doesn't have staying power it doesn't
mean it means less and less all the time
yeah so um so if you i mean if you look
at you know what ideas have persisted
over thousands of years i think geometry
i mean i know i'm using a lot of
mathematical examples but like the idea
of a triangle i mean it's a simple
object we all learn about it in grade
school i mean a triangle had to be
invented by humans we didn't have a
concept of triangles we we had to invent
it and we did it by you know it's
fascinating to me to think about the the
um invention of geometry based on like
surveying the physical landscape of the
earth and sometimes i wonder like how
much perception
of like spatial awareness did we have
like our brains had to evolve that
understanding of space and then we
regularized it by inventing something
called geometry and then that allowed us
to understand that there could be you
know things that didn't conform to flat
geometries for example and imagine all
kinds of things that allow us to do all
kinds of crazy stuff now um
but but all of that has to acquire over
time and then it you know it stays in
the system and so the history of the
evolution of our planet is very
contingent on
you know what what has been thought in
the past and what we're thinking now is
going to really matter to the future
um
which is so i don't i don't disagree i
mean that that makes sense i mean that's
how you build
yeah
a system that's how
something biological evolves is that
there has to be some kind of objective
truths that it keeps building on right
but
is there a chance that i guess that's
not that's not the right way to start it
with a sign right because there's a
chance for about everything but i yeah i
mean
there's always a chance right and i
think that the question for me is always
what things we observe can we actually
build into theories that we can test and
then use those theories to discover new
phenomena
right and in the context of aliens like
you wanna or origins of life you know
the ultimate standard for me
understanding what life is is we can go
in the lab and we can build a physical
simulator of a planet that generates
denavo a life form um or if we go to
look for aliens like we actually have a
tool to be able to detect them without
them looking at all like us
well what if
what if what is objective to us here
which i don't really disagree um what if
what's objective here at another
dimension of reality is no longer
the truth anymore or it's not even that
it's that it's actually more complex and
we don't quite even maybe see the whole
the whole truth of it you know like we
only understand a fractal
of the nature of an objective truth in
this reality
i mean i think that's already true to an
extent like i i couldn't fathom looking
around the room right now and thinking
that my eyes and my ears and my nose and
my my ability to feel physical contact
are actually capturing even a small
slice of things that exist in this room
right now but i i'm a physical structure
with sensory
apparatus that you know allows me to
perceive certain features of reality but
not all of them um and and again this
this goes back to like why i'm so
fascinated by
um that like what technology has like
the evolution of technology is like a
very um
uh
interesting window into this kind of
physics right so so basically i'm saying
all these things that seem kind of
intuitively obvious but they're not
intuitively obvious from the perspective
of physics or how to construct theories
that would explain these features
but um but the example from technology i
like is like you know people will
sometimes speculate with me that well
aliens could be in this room right now
but you wouldn't know because they're
living in a different dimension or
they're doing something and i would just
say well that might be true but how do i
build the test for that and then how do
i actually look at that and you can look
at the history of life on earth um and
you know there's microbes you know
probably all over everything i'm
touching right now right and i don't i
can't see them i don't have any
perception of them but you know we
invented microscopes and then we just
turned them on our table tops and our
bread and we realized the you know the
entire planet is basically littered with
not littered i mean they're they're
thriving and they're wonderful and
beautiful and they they help us be here
too microbes right so we have life all
around us that is you know it's just
it's not something that we have direct
perception of it we might taste taste
the bread is moldy or see the bread is
moldy but did you know that it was
actually organisms growing there that
are alive
you're eating
pretty much i mean it's alien in the
sense that it's very distant in time
from you on the same branch of life that
have emerged on our planet
right so um so my point with with this
example is of course what you're saying
like in the far future they probably
will see more of reality than we do
because we're going to invent things
that allow us to see more of it and i
think ai is actually really important in
this regard artificial intelligence
because for me our artificial
intelligence might actually be the kind
of technology that we develop that
allows us to see the physics of
ourselves we we've built telescopes that
allow us to see deep in the universe
microscopes that allow us to see
microbes you know gravitational wave
detectors that allow us to see these
tiny ripples in the fabric of space-time
um but we don't know what we look like
um you know fundamentally or have things
that can recognize phenomena like us and
i think it's because of this
this i would say in assembly theory
because we are these very large causal
structures that have this very deep
embedding in time and we don't have
instruments that do that but if you
think artificial intelligence is like a
map of our minds that we're projecting
onto technology then maybe it will have
different ways of seeing i mean we can
teach it to have different ways to see
the world than we do and maybe it will
be able to see that physics very clearly
i don't know i'm totally speculating
right now but that's an interesting way
to look at it i mean that's an
interesting way to look at it i've
thought to myself even just with ai that
you know
ai
it's only it's it's limitations of
learning are only what we all know it's
just collectively essentially put into
one thing one being
so it kind of creates a lineage of
thought of
the ultimate question is are we just
a version of ai right that we create the
next sort of piper human that collects
all the information and then it just
kind of keeps leapfrogging is that
um i think to that
um i i think i think what you're
proposing is interesting i would i would
say it a little bit differently so i
don't i don't think thinking of ai as a
monolith
like you know it's like one entity we're
building is the right narrative i think
it's a
um
it's a collection a population a
globally you know just like humans are
distributed globally and we're all
different we all have different
personalities and different intellects
and different abilities to you know some
people have synesthesia so they you know
like like our minds all work differently
right so i and i love examples of people
that have minds that aren't you know
like they're more than one or two
standard deviation from the norm because
they see things that other people don't
or they see connections between things
other people don't um but if you think
about that as like ai as a population of
algorithms that are currently on the
planet you know they they will have
personalities and attributes that are
different from each other and they will
behave cooperatively or antagonistically
with each other and so it's it's more
like a co-evolution a cooperative like
just like life has been um it's not it's
not like
i i don't i i i think of much much more
interesting cooperative collective
effects
and complexity than these kind of you
know it's all about the individual and
survival of fittest and you know like i
just think those things long term are
not right
so if it's
kind of the feedback loop and
growing evolutionarily and it takes a
community and it takes information we
can't do it we can't do it in a silo we
have to have information
then is it just um a larger aggregate of
a community it's just instead of because
essentially into an artificial
intelligence it's getting the
encyclopedia it's getting every google
search it's getting but of course it's
not going to
get every little every bit from the
world right like not every ai is going
to be so it's going to just be
essentially like
instead of having 8 billion people now
essentially there's like 8 people or
whatever 800 that are smaller it's a
it's a larger aggregate of uh it's an
aggregate of a of a mass does that make
am i making sense i didn't understand
the last part so maybe you can explain
that idea a little bit more so just that
if we create an iai here you know i
don't know
elon musk is creating one and and it's
going to collect
you know the data from the united states
well this is kind of like representative
of this information
and so
because everything in the universe is
information
right um
it's some sense yes um so i've been a
big proponent of the idea that
information is fundamental in some sense
in in terms of explaining what we are um
but it's almost like i would go one
level deeper and i'd say we have things
that we talk about as information and we
have things that we talk about as matter
and really the real problem is that
there's something deeper than that where
information and matter look like the
same thing
what level would that be at how far
that's that's that's actually what that
that's the structure of this assembly
theory i'm trying to develop it's it's
it's it's basically about the
relationship between things that exist
the causal relationship so
so we see we talk about matter and we
think about elementary particles um and
i would say elementary particles and the
kind of current physics we have um is
very explanatory for objects that don't
exist in time because they're
instantaneous objects they have no
memory associated to them um and they're
if they exist in the universe they're
very easy for the universe to reproduce
in the next moment but things like us
are deeply embedded in time we have a
very rich causal structure
so that feature of our physics is not
readily apparent unless you look uh look
across time and you actually see that
that's that's sort of a key feature so a
molecule is actually a structure that
exists across time and and and
and has a physical dimension in time so
um so whether that that pans out or i
mean obviously we have to test these
ideas so we're trying to build
experiments that actually validate some
of the predictions from a theory that's
structured that way
but but that would be sort of
um i think an important implication
of of how to think about how would you
recover standard physics versus what's
happening when you get into the world of
complex objects and why they look
different can you explain to me what
vacuum fluctuations are
yeah um so it's the idea that if you
have um in quantum physics if you just
have like energy and you can actually
spontaneously fluctuate um matter
anti-matter pairs into existence um and
so so that's kind of it comes out of
these um
uh sort of the structure of quantum
field theory and the way that we
actually have to account for certain
events of in particle physics we see it
looks like there's this kind of cloud of
particles that are constantly being
generated out of the vacuum that i think
is very accurate for elementary
particles i think where it's not
accurate is when people want to
extrapolate that
to say anything can spontaneously
fluctuate out of the vacuum and actually
you don't even have to go to quantum
physics for that i mean when um when
thermodynamics was invented in the 1800s
you know
boltzmann who was a big developer of uh
thermodynamics um you know came up with
this idea that the entire universe might
be a fluctuation like a rare event of
order out of disorder right um and and
so we see this kind of reoccurring theme
in certain different theories of physics
but i think it again it comes from the
fact that you you can't fluctuate an
entire
history into existence or you would have
to fluctuate the entire history you
can't just get a complex object for free
it couldn't come out of a vacuum though
like particles could not particles can
do particles make life
they do eventually yes it's but it's not
a fluctuation at that point it's a
really it's a deterministic causal
structure that's generated and then
there's also this other issue that when
you you fluctuate vacuums they're always
in matter antimatter pairs so they
quickly annihilate each other because
they basically come into existence right
next to each other and matter
annihilates
antimatter generates the energy that
they fluctuated out of so what you'd
have to do is actually have a mechanism
for separating the matter from the
antimatter and then either the matter
would have to evolve complexity or the
antimatter would evolve from complexity
so if you want to go back to like you
know the origins of the universe or
things and try to talk about mechanisms
of the universe um emerging as some kind
of you know in some multiple scenario or
you have
i don't i don't know what proposal you
might want to do
um you know maybe
i you know at some point you have to
explain the origin of everything i'm
concerned with the origin of us from a
universe that has
matter as we currently understand it in
it
i'm just wondering what what it what it
what we are at a base level
sure sure
i think we all are that's a good
question what what are we at a base
level
so sometimes i talk about life as being
information that structures matter
across space and time
and so what when i think about it from
that perspective what we are like as
humans which is to me the most
interesting phenomena might be very uh
anthropocentric but i still think it's
okay to ask questions about ourselves
is we are
a mechanism for the universe to explore
the space of what could exist
in the sense that we're a generative
mechanism like creating this possibility
of things
that
that wouldn't exist without us existing
so that's again goes back to this part
of being part of this causal chain of
events so so but we happen to be a very
um
uh probably the first structure at least
that's emerged on this planet that has
in some sense um a more universal
understanding and this goes to idea of
imagination right so i think that like
biological evolution most of biological
evolution could draw on things that had
happened on this planet in the past and
use them to survive into the future now
there's something very unique about
us as maybe conscious beings or us as
things that have imagination and the
capacity to build technology that we can
imagine things that have never happened
in our universe and as long as they're
consistent with the laws of physics
energy conservation or
charge conservation these kind of things
then we can build them like we can make
them exist um and so um
you know i'm deeply interested with
people that are platonists like you know
believe that there's some separate world
of mathematical pure forms that somehow
interact with the material world and i
guess the physics i'm interested in is
the fact that we actually exist on that
boundary because we're constantly
generating things
that can exist that haven't existed and
they wouldn't exist without us doing
that and i don't think you need to go to
some deeper level of thinking about you
know the world as the universe as like
some multiverse or something to explain
that i think that the most interesting
thing is to start from us from first
principles and say what is it that we're
doing what is the structure of physics
that would be necessary to accommodate
us and then you can go back and you can
look at quantum physics and you can look
at general relativity and you can say
how is it consistent with those theories
but you know we didn't start trying to
build gr by starting from quantum
physics
right and now we have a problem of
trying to come up with a quantum a
theory of quantum gravity because those
theories don't aren't actually
compatible in certain regimes and but
everybody wants to use those theories to
explain especially quantum physics to
explain us in our minds and but they
weren't designed for that they were
designed to
to um
to
describe certain features of elementary
particles and i think the physics of us
is even weirder
um if i could have put it like flip
quite bluntly i think it's much more
interesting than quantum mechanics is um
in terms of its explanatory power and b
what it tells us about reality and
and also the kinds of
the kinds of features it has associated
to it
but we don't have that theory yet so i i
don't but i don't want to explain us in
terms of quantum mechanics because i
think it's boring and it's not
um
it's it's not nearly creative enough
i love that
what are your thoughts about ancient
civilizations and the theory of ancient
technologies and when you look at the
you know i don't know if it's
necessarily so in your exact sort of
studies and what you research but it
must
play a part in
your imagination
about
what
could be
because of what has been
yeah
i am
i was talking with my mom about this
last night actually
my mom uh
she has very sort of different like like
i said she's an artist and she's um
she's deeply catholic and you know and i
was kind of raised in this kind of um
uh you know she's very spiritual it's so
uh she's really surgery spiritual
spiritual
um
so
i it was interesting because she was she
was asking me this question about
ancient civilizations and
and i think the thing for me that's
challenging is a lot of times there's a
tendency for us to want to have mystical
explanations for things and i don't have
a problem with being open-minded um and
i i don't necessarily have a problem
with mystical explanations but i think
what i would prefer
is an act like a a concrete explanation
that allows us to do things so i so this
is actually like you could distinguish
magic from knowledge in some sense and
that magic is something that like a
single person can talk about knowledge
is something that an entire
uh planetary
uh civilization can actually use to to
move into the future um and i think um
there has been a lot of you know
localized knowledge or things that were
invented that didn't become you know
global scale integrated technologies and
and i guess my point with ancient
civilizations is they had this like
effectively the same neural architecture
we have today if we could invent
something they could invent something
but the the point is that their
technologies were limited or they
bifurcated off in different ways because
they don't have the same sort of history
of the evolution of technology we do
which is technology is very historically
contingent so so my mom wanted to try to
impose that there's some unexplained
thing there and i wanted to say i think
humans are the most amazing generative
mechanisms that the universe has
produced so far so to sell ourselves
short and say ancient cultures couldn't
have done these things and we need some
other explanation to me is selling short
the potential for humans in the future
and what we actually are capable of
because it's just saying we couldn't do
that and i and i don't i don't see
anything i've seen people try to explain
um
mystically that i wouldn't want to
attribute to our own minds um and try to
and so and it doesn't mean that there
aren't other things that could be
interacting it's just that i feel like
as a first principles
and the fact that i
i think we're amazing like i i just i
can't i can't
so um so i think i think we need to
study history i think we need to
understand it better i think there are
definitely mysteries and there are some
things that you know border the profound
or borders you know things that we don't
understand and i guess where i want to
sit personally
is on the frontier of trying to
understand
the things we don't understand
and do it from the perspective of
science because i think i think
personally i think science is really
amazing because it's the one place where
you're always supposed to ask questions
and you're not ever supposed to have the
answer and i think a lot of people
always want to claim they have the
answer and i find that really
challenging for me personally because i
know how few answers we
actually have
to anything that we want to act at this
point in time we think that the we i
mean when you look at the universe and
it being 95
dark energy and dark matter together
right that's just code for i don't get
it right yeah it's it's a very
particular code for i don't get it but
it is it's like a placeholder for we
know the properties of that thing but we
can't explain that thing yeah so that
could apply for ancient civilizations
that we don't get it there's an answer
we this is a placeholder we've got the
pyramids and we've got pyramids all over
the world and we've got all these
stories and things like that and we just
don't
get it right now and it didn't mean that
we weren't a part of it but could it
also mean that there was
a part of ancient history that involved
extraterrestrials
being on this planet and assisting
mankind
i don't think it's the most
useful explanation what else builds
things that we can't even build now
um i i don't know you know my kids build
things i can't build
so no i mean seriously i think it's
severely underestimating uh you know the
power of the human mind i mean
you look at anything that humanity's
created like language i mean who would
think to invent language or geometry
it's just some of that knowledge stayed
and some of it was lost with a
particular civilization and you know i
would be i would be
you know if somebody wanted to make a
convincing case for me about aliens they
should say aliens invented geometry and
like there's
i would be more shocked by actual
knowledge our our biosphere our people
we know we can point to generated than i
would about some physical artifact that
exists like a pyramid i don't i don't
find those to be
compelling evidence you can think about
it with life detection right so like
people they want to go out and find
aliens and they think um you know like
like evidence of ufos is evidence of
aliens or they think finding phosphine
on venus is evidence of aliens and to me
the evidence is not not the thing like
you don't want to make first contact
with something that you don't understand
what we want to make first contact with
when we're trying to understand aliens
is the explanation what is this
phenomena that we're even talking about
so anytime people are making claims that
it's e.t it's pretty much we've put
um we've put a placeholder for other
unexplained thing with aliens
and i think that that needs to be
disentangled because we don't actually
know the phenomena that we're talking
about right and i don't want to jump to
that as the first explanation i actually
want to understand what that thing is
and i i think i think we're capable of
doing that and i think part of the
reason that i'm i'm giving you this sort
of passionate response i want to show
for people to think about the deeper
problem than just kind of look at things
and say oh it must be aliens because we
don't understand it do you believe that
everything is linear i mean is it that
you're i feel like there's there's a
feeling that everything is is working in
a linear fashion and that
oh no like your point about top like i
don't think i don't think like time like
i think time fundamentally time is
ordering of events and they do move
forward but i think time is very complex
i don't think it i don't think it's
linear at all so if you wanted to say um
you know could could could aliens have
visited us in the past i'm not going to
make the sort of standard argument that
the distances in space and stuff are too
large i would just say well let's build
the empirical test to do this and in
fact my my mentor here at
asu paul davies has proposed some of
those kind of tests so for example if
you think ancient aliens visited
billions of years ago not even like why
so the the earth is four billion years
old why would they visit two thousand
years ago and not say one and a half
billion years ago maybe they came two
billion years ago when they missed
seeing us and they you know so how would
they leave a mark um so you know he's
come up with a proposal that's
scientifically testable which is a
little bit crazy like it's a phishing
experiment right like this is really
implausible but you could at least test
it which is um genomic study like you
know we know genomes persist over time
and there's certain information in
genomes that has been on this planet as
long as life has so for example how to
build a ribosome which is a molecular
machine in our bodies ribosomes have the
same structure they had three and a half
billion years ago as far as we can tell
and that's encoded in dna so you could
imagine if you had an extra stress
civilization come to earth and they
wanted something to persist long enough
for intelligence to evolve and decode it
and say hey
um then maybe they would do it in
genomes because genomes are more stable
than rocks um and so you can make these
kind of proposals and the way to test
that is actually to go in genomic
databases and try to look for codes and
genomes and people have done that but
they haven't come up with anything
um but so i guess it's it's just you
know there are a lot of just there are a
lot of like stories we can tell we're
really good at that and mythology is
really important for the progress of the
human species our stories are like one
of the most critical things that we do
but i think understanding the boundary
of when are we talking about things that
we can say concretely versus when are
they
the things that like you know we we
can't then then i want to be the person
that's saying well how could we confirm
that that's the right story
and and i think we can do that with some
of these things we could but i don't see
people that are you know i liked the the
orion mystery about like why are the
chambers of of the pyramids lined up
with orion right like how could they do
that kind of astronomy i think that's
deeply fascinating but i actually can
ask questions and try to find the
answers and if the answer is
extraterrestrial great yeah but i don't
i don't see it being the first thing i
want to
well i actually it is the first thing i
want to run to you right because i want
to like prove aliens are real but i also
want to i want to understand um well i'm
obviously going to ask you i don't want
to lose track of my thought here if you
believe aliens are real or not but well
maybe it's a maybe because you're trying
to prove it um yeah but there's like a
an energy around magic kind of basically
being not real but there's a lot a lot a
lot a lot a lot a lot a lot of things
that we don't understand how they work
right and so
it kind of almost goes back to the first
question where there's an intuition
there's a sort of pattern or an
an experience of reality that doesn't
make sense yet
but you're observing it or you have a
feeling about it or an intuition and
then you spend your time backing into
figuring what the hell that thing is
yeah no i think that's absolutely right
and i think i mean i do science by
intuition yeah there you go
our brains are basically evolved to
perceive reality but they're real
physical systems right so they're like
the understanding of of our universe is
embedded in our brains whether we can
talk about it or not is it
what i mean by that is that we
physically exist and i think i think we
have a lot of deep intuition
about things because of that but you
know i
that's my personal intuition now that
may or may not be right right like could
i validate that that statement i don't
know um but i do know that i operate as
a scientist by following my intuition
about
does this feel like it explains
phenomena does this feel like this is
the right physics and i love this thing
about einstein's like there was some
quote i came across once that like he
could feel a light beam in his belly and
i think like if you're
if you're really you know thinking
deeply about the structure of some like
like intuition can really guide you but
i i think um you know the the challenge
of being a scientist doing that is you
really have to structure it like you
have to be very disciplined and
following your intuition because i think
um you know
part part of it is you know i also i
don't want to just accept things as
we've been taught i really want to
understand how things work and i think
there's sort of this dichotomy where
some people want to take
narratives that we've been told and use
those to try to get people behind a
certain set of stories and i just think
it's really important to empower people
to realize that you know their intuition
matters their understanding matters um
and we really need to appreciate the
diversity of human experience and that
probably in the long run will really
help us understand more about what we
are and what we're doing so i i
completely resonate with that
that kind of viewpoint um
i go to the next level then and so yeah
what do you believe intuition is so i
don't know exactly how to answer that
question i just i i think like emotions
can be a good guide um for things um and
i know a lot of people that are
brilliant like some of the best
scientists i know are super emotional
about thinking like like for me it's
it's a very emotional process it's like
like how people would describe art is
what it's like to try to build new like
being artistic so um so i think i think
that's hugely important but i also
personally think like people think
scientific theory should be the simplest
explanation and for me personally i
think if we want the explanation that's
going to increase the longevity of life
basically like like makes the best
possible future and and part of the
reason i think that is because i think
our intuition and the kind of ideas we
build about reality are actually what
generates
the future for us and so um because
we're we're building it right yeah
we decide to have children we decide to
make cars i think from that perspective
intuition is kind of it's sort of the
steering
uh at least that our minds have through
through what can exist and and how we
want to actually manifest what we want
to but that doesn't really
scientifically explain what intuition is
no um but i don't think it's impossible
to explain what intuition is intuition
magic
no
but it may be oh in the sense that it's
unique to a person it might be well and
that it's also not explainable like
um i don't think it's not
not explainable but i do appreciate the
the perception so there there is this
interesting question which i think is
where you keep trying to push me and
it's really hard because i'm really
resisting it um but you know you know
i'm open-minded enough to try to go
there a little bit so that's good um so
um
but you know there is there is this
really fascinating question about what
is the boundary of what's knowable right
because we don't know you know like
science has taken us far and we have you
know an explanation of things or even
literature has taken as far like i'm a
scientist i talk about science but like
you think about any human endeavor from
art to sport to
literature to religion they have all
expanded the boundary of what we think
is possible or how we think about things
and the question is like how much is
really concretely knowable which is kind
of the you know and
and
and i think in science that's a really
hard question because we don't know how
far the boundary of our understanding
can go we don't know the limitations of
our own minds we don't know the
limitations of our physical you know
like our physical architecture as as
as you know biological things so um
so i think that's a really
deep question
um and i don't think it's one that's
necessarily readily ansible
i don't know if it'll ever be answerable
i kind of
i kind of see
knowledge as this explain expanding
wavefront that like
as life has evolved it's expanded
its reach in terms of what it can
explain and understand and i i don't
necessarily see a limitation to that
process because the space of what can
exist
is absolutely huge i mean people think
physical space like the physical size of
the universe is large
but i like to point out that the number
of molecules that could be produced on
this planet based on like the amount of
chemistry that we know or biology knows
is
like exponentially
really large it's hard to compare a
combinatorial space to like a geometric
space but it's just it's huge yeah and
you don't have enough resources in the
entire universe to make all possible
uh you know proteins which are you know
a molecule in our body you know like a
length 200 unit amino acid protein don't
have enough resources universe to make
all possible versions of that molecule
to the power of
yeah there's a yes there's a lot of to
the power of to the power to the power
of and so i just think when you get to
things that are complex like us that
space is huge and we don't think of that
as a physical space but what i'm trying
to say in terms of constructing a
physics of life is to think about the
space of all the possible things that
could exist as the actual landscape that
you do that physics on yeah and then we
we exist somewhere in that space of what
could possibly exist but we are
particularly interesting things in that
space because we're generative in that
space we generate more things
that possibly exist
i was kind of just also
mentioning something that you trust and
use but yet not proven like there's
no that's that play
but it doesn't mean that they aren't
tried and true it doesn't mean that
their our intuition if we look back in
time we can see how good it is but we
don't know where the hell that comes
from
yeah i suppose i see where you're going
with that i don't have a problem
trusting my intuition and not knowing
why i have the intuition and i also i
mean i think it's also interesting
because people under appreciate how much
you think subconsciously and so i think
about myself as having a healthy
dialogue between my conscious and
subconscious is obviously like it's kind
of a one-way conversation because i'm
only consciously aware of the conscious
part but what i mean by that is certain
ideas you know like
i push them to the back of my brain and
i just let them stay there and suddenly
and then they come back and you know i
have some new insights or some
understanding that i kind of knew
consciously all along but i didn't
always really know
and so i think the levels of like what
our brains are doing and how they're
processing information and how we use
that to guide how we do creative things
um is deeply interesting and currently
we don't understand that um and i'm okay
like i'm okay with that in the pursuit
of the kind of problems i'm interested
in because
um it's the nature of your skills it's
the nature of your field that there's a
whole lot of things that you're trying
to answer that's the job right so
it doesn't surprise me that it's okay
that you don't understand it and
um
you know maybe that'll be something that
will be scientifically explained at some
point in time
in science suspending disbelief is
sometimes really important but that's
true for any creative enterprise right
so you know like there's certain things
you were taught are true and then you
have to go out like i mean i could talk
about i i'm a physicist that thinks the
second law of thermodynamics is wrong
like that entropy should always increase
in systems and so that like this idea
that the universe isn't like it should
be increasing disorder and that's just
the directionality that time sets for
things is it equally increasing in order
too
uh no like the second law basically says
it's so basically it comes from thinking
about uh like a gas of particles in a
box um and you know an ordered
configuration might be you have all the
particles in the corner of the box and
so they have a very localized location
and there's very few configurations that
you can stick all of them in the corner
but if you think about them evenly
distributed there's a lot of ways you
can rearrange them all and so that would
be like a high entropy state and so
thermodynamics basically says that all
systems should be increasing entropy
over time and there's mathematical
arguments for that and it's validated in
all kinds of simple physical systems but
people want to apply that to the
universe as a whole so say the universe
is going to a heat death in the
long-term future or to the biosphere
like you know biology is somehow you
know uh temporarily averting the second
law of thermodynamics by making ordered
things and i think it's a it's a
it's
it there's a few problems with that one
is when you construct theories of
thermodynamics you have to talk about
ensembles of identically prepared
systems so if you want to apply it to
the universe you have to say there's a
whole bunch of universes that are
identical and we're doing statistics
and i don't think that makes sense and
um and it also depends how you label
states so there's this issue in some
theories of physics that the
measurements you take kind of matter to
the the structure of what you get out um
and in that case you know if i
i might have a you know depending on
what i can observe i'll talk about
maximum entropy over the observables but
you know there then if i observe more
features is it you know like how do i so
there's this issue of constraints and
observables and things that's really
interesting in the way that we
label things okay mathematically as the
universe the universe is expanding i
mean that's just that's happening right
yeah so so yeah that's what dark energy
is supposed to be if the universe is
expanding is that
the opposite of entropy
no um it's different mechanisms so um
but that's actually good intuition
um that you have there
because i actually think that um
if you had the right theory physics it
might be connected so i i have this
colleague i work with lee cronin that's
um
uh
you know he's a polymath and a chemist
and everything and he told me his theory
of dark energy was actually like time
and i thought it was the most ridiculous
thing i ever heard in my entire life but
i actually over the years working
because we work on this theory assembly
theory together i've kind of understand
what he means and he just means that
time is a mechanism for generating um
like states in the universe and so if
time is moving forward it's actually
generating more states the universe
actually has bigger as time gets further
and that idea seems logically consistent
now you'd have to go you know build a
whole theory based on that but that
that's something that is kind of
implicit in the theory that we're
building to explain life and that's also
in a different way
the way i was thinking about it is that
life is somehow like an entropy over
paths rather than configuration so what
i mean by that is if you think about the
transformations on physical things
rather than counting the physical things
you have in your system and where they
are that maybe life is somehow an
entropy in that space and both of those
ideas are actually very closely related
to what you suggested but from different
spectrums
so i think i think we don't understand
the relationship between our own ideas
most of the time yeah
we have a lot to figure out
so do you believe
i mean do you believe in aliens then um
so
it's a hard word for me to leave
but no but but i mean that in a way like
i i'm somebody that always wants to
believe i have an open mind i have a lot
of um
uh
but but i think i think what i i would
like to prove they exist
um i don't know if they do or not and i
think like for me based on the the sort
of evidence in in science is
you know we don't have uh concrete
evidence one way or the other whether
alien life exists or not and some people
might cite the point you made earlier
life emerged very early on earth we're
here
very early very quickly right so that
might suggest the original life is easy
to happen
and people made this argument but there
is also the issue that if the
origin of life didn't happen quickly on
our planet we might not be here to be
talking about that having happened
because we wouldn't have had the
necessary time to actually even evolve
to have the conversation about the
original life so there's this issue when
you when it's called post selection when
you actually look at the end state and
you're trying to explain the likelihood
of the origin it's conditionally
dependent
um and so when people actually do proper
statistics on that it comes out that
it could be that life is completely
common in the universe based on a rapid
origin of life on earth or it's totally
uncommon we just don't have enough
constraints because we're contingent on
like we wouldn't exist without that
having happened so it could be really
rare and we could just happen to be the
people they're observing it's a
generalization well it's not it's a it's
a specific case of the anthropic
principle which is this idea that the
universe might be fine-tuned for life
out of the multiverse and we just happen
to find ourselves in this particular
universe but specifically for the
problem of the origin life
they've proven that there are like 40
billion planets that have habit are
habitable based on
certain biological factors that we have
correct right but habitable is debatable
right so yeah i mean
i don't want to live in the sahara i
mean like exactly so um
i don't either even though i live in
even
in the sahara
yeah almost just not quite um but also
um so so that that's one issue
habitability habitable for whom sure it
would all have the same habitability
conditions because that's a pretty like
a precondition for life but we don't
know what life is and we don't know what
it depends on and then the second is we
don't actually know
uh we don't have any constraints right
now on the likelihood of matter
transitioning to life i mean that's the
origin of life problem we don't have an
answer to that problem so we can't
constrain the likelihood of that event
happening elsewhere in the universe
because we don't have the theory or the
the actual mechanisms we don't
understand how that happens
so i i a lot of my astrobiologist
colleagues are very you know willing to
um
to point out that life should be common
because plant habitable plants are
common and it's sort of a common thing
people say but i i just
i
it could be the case but i don't want to
say it is the case because we don't know
do you believe then that
you know because we were talking about
it for quite a while but consciousness
that it's sort of an epi phenomenon
of humans or
do you think that there is
a way that that becomes the
neural
link to everything
or other things even let's start with
saying i don't think i don't think that
theories for physics that start from
consciousness as the fundamental thing
actually could work um so i don't think
you can start from consciousness being
the thing that exists before everything
else and then have things work i think
consciousness is something
some other kind of physics generated
potentially
like we don't come in with it you're
saying it's saying as humans there was
some point in time where all of a sudden
we had consciousness
um i think it's much more gradual i
don't believe like i i don't think that
things are alive or not alive i think
it's much more of a continuum and i
think consciousness to a degree has some
of those features but i guess the
question is like what would be the first
experience or maybe it is abrupt like
you either have experience or you don't
um and of course there's there's people
that think everything experiences but i
think that would be really hard to
uh demonstrate empirically
uh you know like
so i i think the question is what
becomes the better explanation that
explains more of things and allows you
to predict more things or to generate
more things
is it unique to humans or do you think
that consciousness has this
a reach beyond
us
i think it's potentially the latter i
think it's hard to talk about that so
like for me personally a lot of my
conscious experience is cast in the form
of language so a lot of my thoughts are
in language like the ones i'm
consciously aware of i have a hard time
um like i can visualize things but i i
you know i can't i haven't can't have a
conscious experience of taste that's
that's separate from
uh actually tasting something so like
there's there's certain things you know
everybody's
architecture their mind is slightly
different so like i have friends that
don't are like their conscious
experience or the way they think about
things is not in language at all and
they have a hard time translating their
thoughts into like a dream think about a
dream i mean you wake up in the morning
and you're like slow i would and then
you think you're visualizing it so
perfectly but then you try and explain
it and it eludes you exactly yeah so but
but i also think that we under so we put
so much emphasis on our conscious
experience that we don't always think
about what the subconscious is doing and
and for me i i personally i think my
subconscious is doing most of the heavy
lifting even in my intellectual like
day-to-day existence because a way ideas
come into my mind and how long i know
that they've been sitting in my brain
without you know and people talk about
those creative moments or sleeping on an
idea and then suddenly everything clicks
into picture so so i guess from that
perspective i know that comes from the
subconscious i think so yeah i mean i
like the like i mean if you're not aware
of it you don't experience it right it's
technically not your consciousness right
but some things might come connected to
something else
um the guy just interviewed bruce lipton
and he is like i mean like
oh he's uh he's a scientist or he's a
he's a doctor he studied genetics and
then he studied the phenomenon he
realized what epigenetics was and he
understood how genes having an
expression
and the conversation was about the
subconscious and the conscious and that
the subconscious is the programming
and that the conscious mind is sort of
the creative intuitive mind and that the
subconscious is the program yeah sort of
operates how we walk it's how we talk
yeah
i kind of think about it that way but i
actually i think most of the creativity
happens subconsciously and for most
creatives i think that's true actually
henry poince who's a very famous
mathematician had this wonderful essay
on how mathematical ideas are created
and he really talked about this like
combinatorial space in like that you
know you're not like thinking and aware
of where all the ideas are recombined
and then they come back up to your
conscious like and then you can think of
the mathematical idea or whatever it is
but i think for most people that are
really creative
i i think we have very little awareness
of what we're doing creatively like in
our conscious experience when we're
doing it um
so i mean it goes back to like you you
asked me this question very early on
about thinking about
you know when did i know what i was
doing
you know because it takes a lot of
experience but you know the way that i
experience that personally is i'll say
things for years and then suddenly i'll
have a moment where i'm like i really
understand why i was saying that for
years yeah
and it's because the depth of
understanding i think you know i might
you know i i had some understanding of
it but i wasn't you know necessarily as
clearly understanding in my conscious
experience like in the way i could
articulate it in language
of what was hap what i was thinking as i
became over time because it takes a long
time to process complex ideas
um and you think that that was and you
think that that is a just an intelligent
moment of understanding something to
some degree but not all the way and not
something sort of in the field or
through intuition that is beyond our
experience that we can understand here
scientifically yet
um
i guess i i would i would again be sort
of halfway stance like i don't think the
the way that you're describing it is
necessarily incorrect but i would not
use those words to describe it um and
what i mean by that is like
um
i think
i think we're picking up information all
the time so every interaction you have
with a person i mean people talk about
body language and things and you're all
these things that are just not in the
verbal report that they're giving you um
and they're also i mean in the pandemic
we all suffered so much because we were
isolated from each other but like just
being in the room and being creative
with a person in three dimensions like
there's just more information and more
um like
there's just more capacity to really
understand what the other person is
saying and so i guess for me i think um
i feel like when i'm doing science one
of the things that i do
is i like to survey what everybody's
thinking like so i try to listen to what
all all the people in a particular field
are saying and i try to look at what
they're say all saying but not saying
with words but what i mean by that is
they are saying it with words and they
think they're saying those things but it
goes back to the fact that language is
imprecise and they're all actually
talking past each other slightly and
it's almost like it's like science is
like a mosaic to me there's like one
picture of reality that we have with all
the pieces in it and then you can just
look at it and you can be like oh
there's a completely different painting
here and so you just rearrange all the
pieces and then you see it you have the
same pieces but there's a totally
different picture and i i think i think
when people have intuition or they're
they are seeing things other people
aren't seeing but i think it's just
because you know like all of our minds
work differently and and we can intuit
different things and we look at
different patterns um
and i think that's really important um
but i i and and maybe we don't
understand all the features of how that
works yet um and i'm okay with that
i'm curious what the
what is the um main question
that you hope to answer
um
to have answered in this lifetime
maybe maybe you're a part of the final
you're always going to be a part of the
final answer maybe it comes while you're
still in your job but what is the
question you hope that we can
have a solution or a formula for i love
this question i always tell my students
that i want to know what life is before
i die
but i mean i really mean like what we i
want to know what we are i want to know
how life arises in the universe and i
want to know if you know what it what is
the variety of phenomena that are like
us um
i i really
i i just you know like i'm always
mystified like people want to look at
the stars and say like the stars are so
amazing there's so many of them out
there isn't it great and i'm just like
look at you comprehending what a star is
aren't you the most amazing physical
thing in the universe like i mean just
like if you think about like the the
magnitude of the phenomena that exists
on this planet just encapsulated in
human minds it's just it's absolutely
profound and um and i just i i really
think if i think about
you know the long-term future for us i
think at a certain point we really have
to understand ourselves at a deeper
level to understand the context of like
even what's happening on this planet now
if you think about existential threats
and things like we have to know what we
are that we're not going to know where
we're going i agree with you i hope that
i hope it's coming as soon as possible
me too
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button